hey guys
oh i am so excited to bring you the new
and
actual trailer to our extraordinary film
disney's jungle cruise
i am so sorry about earlier something
very weird happened um it was like this
rogue trailer this this uh this
desperate delusional sad trailer air
that bears no relation to the film that
we made
um it was like it was like how can i say
it was like the trailer had lost its
mind
that's what it feels like it feels like
it's lost its mind so so here we are
we're gonna rectify that right now and
the birds are out for you the animals
are out to celebrate this moment this is
it this is the true to life
trailer of our extraordinary film that
follows my character
dr lily houghton she's like indiana
jones she is brave and
fearless and wild and she's
brilliant-minded
and humble and she's going to be the one
to take you down the amazon river
on this adventure of a lifetime oh
and there's this um there's a lovely
little up-and-comer in it um
drives the bow um oh what's his name
this is a problem you blink and you'll
miss him you know um dave
dave gobson that's his name
so here we are i'm thrilled that you're
about to see this my heart is
racing that you're going to see our film
so soon this is it this is disney's
jungle cruise
legend has it there is a tree in the
amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers
and the arrowhead is the key to
unlocking it
stop her hello uh just wanted you to
know this has been mislabeled
[Music]
he's shipping outlets
we're headed up river to blagremas de
cristal we must secure our travel come
on
not a good time my brother and i are
looking for passage up river please go
away
i have a lot of money
if you believe in legends you should
believe in curses too
it's not a fun vacation well i'm not
here for a vacation
what are you gonna beg me to turn back
allow me to manage my own safety
oh god sorry frank sorry strong form
oh i got you hold on
i don't got it no no no no no no what
can this say just leave me alone that
was a disaster it didn't go the way i
planned